la chronique que ce pas avoir à suivre
la chronique de sport et bat anthony
alors vouloir entamer un nouveau bon
soir on va commencer petit jingle pour
acquis je n'y ai pas le droit ou tingle
ce soir c'est pas grave on va commencer
avec le vendée globe
on suit toujours un tanguy de lamotte le
skipper versailles et mais après neuf
jours de course cette édition 2012 est
plutôt impitoyable avec les skippers
jérémie beyou a annoncé ce midi son
abandon suite à une avarie de quille
c'est le cinquième depuis le départ des
sables d'olonne après celui ce week end
de louis burton le skipper bureau vallée
cette entreprise qui le soutient qui est
basé au quai sous bois concernant tanguy
de lamotte le versaillais toujours 14e
de la course à 770 milles du leader
armel le cléac'h il habite en ce moment
au large du cap vert les conditions en
mer se sont améliorées depuis vendredi
matin pour le pour le navigateur et
l'unis vinoy alors que le pot-au-noir le
fameux pot-au-noir se profile cette zone
où il n'y a pas de vent ou la navigation
est très très difficile
on le voit d'ailleurs à l'image le
skipper illinois tanguy de lamotte qui
fait son premier vendée globe à l'âge de
34 ans le skipper d'ailleurs
l'initiative coeur continue donc sa
route tranquillement et sûrement mais ce
tour du monde est aussi prenants et
stressant pour ses proches nous sommes
donc allés la rencontre de sa mère
sabine de la motte je vous propose de
l'écouter au micro de genk ans
c'est sûr que moi je fais pas un vendée
globe comme le sien ferveur des globes
en solo ça c'est sûr
j'ai la chance d'être avec de
l'assistance et une assistance amicale
très très forte effectivement mon vendée
globe il est à terre je gère des
émotions voilà et qui sont des émotions
paradoxal parce qu'il ya la joie et
l'inquiétude les quiétudes évidente
d'une mère et l'inquiétude d'un être
humain aussi et la joie parce que c'est
un projet fantastique en fait on essaye
de le vivre en lâchant aussi il faut pas
non plus accroché à toutes les deux
heures alalalala sinon on entretient une
angoisse une inquiétude qui n'est pas
forcément saine puisque toi sont peut
rien faire la chronique de sports du
lundi on suivra donc un régulièrement
avancé de la compétition du vendée globe
pour ce skipper versailles et
de peut-être de la voir la semaine
prochaine dans la chronique en direct
par téléphone